businesses boil down to information  arbitrage every single business that you  ever have seen that exists simply exists  because the one person who's doing the  thing understands more about the thing  than the person they're selling it to so  whether you're raising cattle it means  that you know how to go and farm cattle  you know how to raise them you know how  to breed them you know how to grow them  you know how to manage that versus  somebody who's buying the piece of meat  every single type of business whether  it's e-commerce whether it's service  whether it's software someone knows  something that someone else doesn't  who's buying it and so the key to being  successful in the business that you have  is to always maintain that information  advantage so that you can maximize the  leverage that you have over the  opportunity that you're pursuing